now you know that there are in fact
three separate groups of people working
together to look out for your safety
around annex coast but there is a force
can you get who it is that's right it's
new
by learning and recognizing flags
looking out
listen to the way a report and making
sure to ask the lifeguards for advice
newer
member of the water safety team but what
would happen if someone going to trouble
on the beach and no one knew they were
there who knows where they are who can
help them that's right no one you should
never play or swim on your own around
our coast in case there's no one else
around if you get into trouble on your
own there be nobody around to help you
this also means if you go out you should
always let parents or guardians know
where you are and when you will be back
if you want to be safe you should always
swim with family or friends on a
lifeguarded beach many of us have these
and if you do have one you need to take
it with you when you go out because if
someone gets in trouble you can dial 999
and ask for the Coast Guard that is one
of the most important things you should
remember if you or anyone else is in
trouble at the beach ask for help if the
lifeguards are not around should always
dial 999 and ask for the Coast Guard
but just as important if you see someone
in distress in the water what you don't
want to do is getting yourself to help
them this could really in danger your
own life and certainly wouldn't do them
any favors so what should you do should
always keep yourself safe first it's
like Fort Lee getting into trouble to
you need to be safe in order to help
others so once again if you're in
trouble what should you do that's it
don't 999 and ask for the Coast Guard if
someone is close enough for you to throw
a life ring to then you can try that
this goes for using the life-saving
equipment along the beach as well if you
don't know how to use it or aren't
strong enough to use it you could find
yourself in just as much danger as the
person in the water remember the most
important thing always keep yourself
safe first so remember these things next
time you go to the beach